for anyone looking for solutions there's
no place like home
this is the Cohen residence a pleasant
three-bedroom in Snowmass Colorado but
lurking beneath the surface an energy
eating monster more than half the
electricity in the United States goes
into buildings in one form or another
many homes waste more energy than they
use a team of eco detectives is
investigating the Cohen house for crimes
against the climate this
innocent-looking thing here when it is
on eats a whole lot of money when I feel
this much cold on the outside of the
freezer I know that the insulation is
really not as thick as we would as we
would like for a marine Lovins solutions
start with efficiency reducing the use
of energy that produces co2 emissions I
think once people understand the climate
protection puts money back in your
pocket because you don't have to buy all
that fuel political resistance is going
to melt faster than delay sure's little
red light on the corner Lovins is the
sort of New Age meter reader hell-bent
on killing wasted watts if you have all
kinds of appliances and are your TV your
VCR your DVD etc that have that little
light on yes they're using electricity
it's called vampire loads a hundred and
nine watts it's almost 60 bucks a year
just sitting there turned off if every
household in the u.s. killed off their
wasted vampire loads we could eliminate
at least 18 coal-fired power plants
next to our homes the second-largest
source of emissions we're responsible
for is parked right outside cars
produced nearly 20% of global greenhouse
gases nowhere is the problem of
emissions from transportation more
urgent than in developing countries
especially China I don't think we can
turn round to the Chinese and say I'm
sorry we need to save the future of the
planet the rich countries have to take
the lead and we have to cut our
emissions in a much more dramatic sense
in order to allow some room for growth
in the poorer countries to keep warming
below the critical 2 degree threshold we
need to cut 7 billion tons of greenhouse
gas emissions every year doubling the
average fuel efficiency of all cars from
15 miles per gallon to 30 would save 1
billion tons but we would still need to
cut billions more from our carbon
footprint to stay on the safe side of
plus 2 degrees we have an arsenal
solutions already it's to be solar it's
gonna be wind and it's gonna be tidal
powering that's going to be thermal
power all of these different things
working together actually give us a
pretty good ability to get away from the
fossil fuel economy
right now the average temperature has
only risen 0.8 degrees Celsius but we
don't have much time